you may be the first to wish happy
birthday to Kerry Washington a star of
one of our favorite shows scandal is
turning 39 on Sunday happy early
birthday Kerry and Cameron Mathison
joint Kerry in Cambridge today where the
George Washington University graduate is
being honored by Harvard University so
2016 is like not even a month and yet it
is off to a great start Kerry is being
toasted and roasted by Harvard
University's famed Hasty Pudding
theatricals which means a crazy parade
with students and Dragons
given to performers who have a sense of
humor and make contributions to society
miss Washington has always spoken up a
woman of color what's great about what
is happening this year with the Oscars
is it's giving us an opportunity to talk
about these things in a way that's a
little bit more honest and I think we've
talked about them in the past so great
always about inclusivity as a brand
ambassador for Neutrogena she loves the
healthy skin liquid makeup they launched
an expanded shades for all ethnicities
this is no cocoa color which is my color
that did not exist before but now exists
for girls that look like me healthy
skinned
posting pics of her manicures she also
reps OPI nail color who Vinod do her
daughter Isabelle I love the fact that
you named one of your nail polishes
after your little girl was that inside
the Isabel way and that color is just a
really beautiful nude but it's a nude
for a skin tone closer to mine so when I
was growing up in people said nude like
nude stockings it didn't mean a person
of color they reminded me of her little
newton s/o one day she's gonna hate me
to say that on television